we're here today at Dreer Farms
announcing open access to our
blueberries right into China this is
going to be a great benefit to Farmers
right here in British Columbia opening
more and more markets for us is
obviously help helping us to Market our
product to uh keep the prices up as the
blueberries are coming on more and more
we need more places to ship them it's a
great thing for blueberry producers
because it allows us to diversify our
markets it's allows us to employ more
labor keep labor force more active at
allows a whole host of things uh
opportunity for higher revenues on some
some products and hopefully over the
next few years as we wrap up we'll get
about $65 million more in export value
out of our blueberries into the Chinese
[Music]
market